- I'd like to introduce
our first speaker of the day.
Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk
builds businesses.
Fresh out of college he took a
family wine business and grew it
from $3 million to
$60 million in just five years.
Now he runs VaynerMedia,
one of the world's hottest
social media
first digital agencies.
Along the way, Gary became a
prolific angel investor and
venture capitalist investing in
companies including Facebook,
Twitter, Tumblr, Uber, Birch Box
before cofounding Vayner/RSE,
a $25 million investment fund.
He's got a track
record of success.
Gary was named to both Crane and
Fortune magazine's 40 under 40
list in the past year.
He has profiled
in New York Times,
Fortune and Inc. magazines
and is frequently
sought to share his expertise on
CNN, Bloomberg TV,
CNBC and many more.
He's here today to provide
a unique perspective on the
changing perception of value.
I have my own kinda
interaction with Mr. Vaynerchuk.
I'm watching 60 Minutes the
other day and he comes on
60 Minutes and I go,
"He's our speaker."
That was so cool.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please help us welcome
Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applause)
("Can't Stop The Feeling"
by Justin Timberlake)
- [Gary] First and foremost,
I want to thank my mom
for writing that intro.
(audience laughter)
That was nice.
I'm really excited to be here.
I'm gonna give you context on
how I got here and then actually
I'm gonna pontificate on what
I believe but mostly I'd like to
leave as much time as possible
for Q&amp;A because I think theory
is lovely but the fact of the
matter is I'm very obsessed
with the practitionership.
And the goal that I have here
which is I think I'll be talking
about a lot of stuff that people
are either blind to or don't
want to believe or aren't doing
and the reality is I'll deploy a
lot of the energy that I was
naturally gifted with and we'll
all feel good and debate and
then it will be next Thursday
and you'll be back to your norm
and a lot of this won't happen.
And so, my big goal very
honestly here this morning is to
get one or two people to
understand how phenomenal the
opportunity for our businesses
is in the new world and try to
shift what I know is the
collective appetite towards the
landscape that I market in and
build businesses in which is a
lot of people look at
these things as a negative.
A lot of people look at these
things as something they didn't
grow up with and they go
completely in the defense
instead of understanding
the offense of all of this.
So, let me start by saying this,
I love social media
because of two things.
Number one, it's just the
word that represents the current
state of the internet.
I think when people hear the
term "social media" it's very
easy to kind of think
it's this nice to have
up-and-coming little thing.
When you understand that this is
now the primary device of every
human being in our society and
over 50% of every minute that is
spent on this device is spent
on one of those seven websites,
you know,
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
Snapchat, YouTube, LinkedIn it
starts to get a little harder to
completely disrespect it as
something that may
sell somebody a product.
And so, for me, I love social
media because it sells stuff.
I want to set the
tone very quickly here.
I did not own a computer
until I was 19 years old.
I was not techy.
I was an awful student.
I don't love technology.
I don't give a
crap about gadgets.
I don't even want to ever own a
drone but I know I will have to
at some point.
I'm not into this.
I'm into making money because
I want to buy the New York Jets.
(audience laughter)
And so and
I think this is important.
The reason I'm more excited,
so I'm running out of here after
this keynote and I'm
going to Las Vegas to CES,
the computer electronic show and
I will spend the next two days
spending all my time with the
Fortune 500 CMOs who pay me tens
of millions of dollars to do
their marketing and to be very
honest there is no comparison to
the excitement that I have for
this 60 to 90 minutes
in comparison to that.
Not because of the money or the
stage but because I'm so much
more you than I am them.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I came to U.S. when I was three.
We were ridiculously poor.
My family lived in a
studio apartment in Queens,
New York with eight family
members in an apartment the size
of the stage
that I'm on right now.
My dad made two dollars an hour
being a stock boy in a liquor
store in Clark, New Jersey
and that's where I come from,
that's who I am.
I didn't know my dad until I was
14 years old because he would
leave before I woke up and got
home after I slept 'cause he
worked every day as a
stock boy and then a manager.
And I don't know if
any of you are immigrants,
anybody here an immigrant
or a child of an immigrant?
Immigrants have a
really interesting strategy.
It's called don't spend any
money on anything for a decade.
(audience laughter)
And that's what my
parents did and they
saved and my dad eventually
bought a small liquor store in
Springfield, New Jersey.
We moved to Edison, New Jersey
when my dad became the manager
of the Clark, New Jersey
liquor store and that's where my
entrepreneurial career began.
When I was six, I had a
five lemonade stand franchise.
(audience laughter)
I manipulated,
tricked, depends on
how you want to word this,
my friends to stand behind the
lemonade stands when I was in
first grade and
I would ride my Big Wheels.
How many of you
remember Big Wheels?
That little toy.
I used to ride my Big Wheels
at the end of the day to my
locations and pick
up my cash like I was
Tony Soprano or something.
(audience laughter)
So that's who I am.
I mean I'm starting to
paint you a very clear picture.
I actually, you know what?
This is the perfect crowd.
I don't usually tell
this part of the story.
Actually that was
my second business.
My first business for about
two months before I segued into
lemonade was to run
around the neighborhood,
rip people's flowers out of
their yards and then ring their
doorbell and
sell it back to them.
(audience laughter)
So you're about to
hear a lot of noble,
care about your
customers, customer service,
word-of-mouth stuff but that's
the seed that I come from so
don't think I'm Mother Teresa.
When I was 12, I started
my first big business.
I'm 41 so anybody in that age
group probably it skews a little
bit more male but if you're in
that age group baseball cards
were the real pop
culture thing for us in fifth,
sixth, seventh, eighth, ninth,
tenth grade and I was making
$2-3000 a weekend selling
baseball cards in
the malls of New Jersey.
And I don't know about you but
when you're 13 and 14 and you
have $30,000 in cash under your
bed and you're not selling weed,
you're doing a good job.
(audience laughter)
So, you know, it's
really fascinating.
I'm sure for a lot of you, you
feel this too as I look around
kind of get the
demo of this audience.
It's fascinating that
entrepreneurship is now cool.
It's crazy to me that people
follow me on the internet and
think like I have micro
internet celebrity around
just being a businessman.
For me, when I was growing up
getting D's and F's in school
which is what I did was
extremely rare for an immigrant
and was unbelievable that my
parents kind of gave me that
freedom to be the
entrepreneur that I was.
But it wasn't cool
to be a businessperson.
You know, grades were
the proxy of your success.
So I sit here and I think so
much about how much opportunity
came to me because of
the scale of the internet.
I was a D and F student.
I went to college.
I came home every weekend to
work at my dad's liquor store.
I fell in love with
wine when I was 15 or 16
because people collected it.
I hated working at my dad's
liquor store the first two or
three years because I was in
the basement bagging ice all day
making two bucks an hour.
I hated it instead of making
$1000 being a baseball card
dealer at the
mall, my own thing.
But some around 16, I realized
that people collected wine and
I loved my family and I wanted
to help and like any good punk
entrepreneurs 16-year-old,
I thought I could do it better
than my dad and
so I wanted to help.
I was very self-aware and
empathetic to this amazing
opportunity my family created
for me and I wanted to give back
to that business
but I wasn't interested
in selling beer or liquor.
The wine thing was very
fascinating to me and at 16,
17 I went all-in, pot committed
and learned more about wine than
any child should.
And that became my passion.
I went to college.
I'm in my dorm room in
1994, September of 1994.
I'm playing Madden '94,
dominating by the way,
and my friend
comes in and he goes,
"You have to come and see this."
I end my game,
I walk into the room and
my buddy's sitting there.
Just a couple of them
and they're at a computer.
Now, I'm really one,
there's some youngsters in here.
For people of my age and
above this will make sense.
I mean I had
literally at this point,
I'm about to turn 19.
At literally at this
point have spent
15 hours on the computer.
Right, nine.
I mean like probably computer
class but since I was trying to
sell baseball cards during
class I wasn't really on it.
So I'm in front
of this computer.
I mean I brought a word
processor to do my papers on.
Like just to wrap,
this is only 20 years ago.
Let's stick with this and then I
hear sound the changes my life
which (imitates dial-up modem).
Some of you might remember that.
The dial-up internet game where
AOL was charging two bucks a
minute after you used up your
free minutes and I said some
profound thing like, "Is this
the information superhighway?"
Because I had
heard of this thing.
And within a couple of minutes
my friends were on chat rooms
trying to get girls.
And within the first
time that I sat again,
one more time
for the youngsters,
I actually watched
people on the internet
for 4 1/2 hours because
it was so crazy and then I
waited my turn and I got on the
internet within about an hour
I realized that there were these
chat rooms and bulletin boards
that were
selling baseball cards.
And within 24 hours
of being on the internet,
I realized that instead
of opening up 1,000 wine
superstores across the country
and building the Toys "R" Us of
wine that I was
going to do this thing.
And a year and
half later in 1996,
I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in
America called WineLibrary.com
and that was a good decision
except, and this
is super important,
this is going to
really relate to what I hope
to achieve in this room.
What I'm gonna go into and what
I'm gonna do in the Q&amp;A with you
guys is try to push you to spend
time and money on storytelling
why somebody should buy your
services and your pool or spa
through the
platforms that exist here.
I'm going to tell you with a lot
of data and a crap load of heart
why I can replicate direct mail,
like I'm doing every day for
Wine Library right now, and
deliver 4 to 6 times the result
by making Facebook
ads act like direct mail
instead of direct mail.
I will do all that over the next
hour and change but here's the
part you have to
listen to carefully of where
Sasha Vaynerchuk, my dad,
did something really well.
I launched
WineLibrary.com in 1996.
It cost $15,000.
I just want
everybody to understand,
our business was doing
$3 million and change in top
line revenue on
10% gross profit.
We were taking home $340,000
a year before our expenses.
Luckily, he didn't have a whole
lot of employees and he was able
to take home a little
bit of money but we were not
making a lot of money.
The prior six years' marketing
budget was less than $15,000.
And I don't mean per year.
I mean combined.
So I spend $15,000 as
a small business in 1996
to launch WineLibrary.com.
Couple of fun facts.
Number one, I knew nothing about
technology or the internet.
The Russian guy named Alex that
built it for me ripped me off at
a level where is
there camera here?
Yeah, Alex if I find you,
I'm gonna slice your throat.
(audience laughter)
Sorry, I just
needed that for me.
So, I spent $15,000 on
a piece of crap website and
in the first year we sold
$817 worth of wine
on the website
for the entire year.
Now I don't know how many of you
have a Soviet father but that
was not the ROI that
Sasha was looking for.
What's important is is that it
took me time to figure out what
was going on in that world.
I was still going to school so
it was half-pregnant but the
punchline is that same business
when I took over and was back
from school full time on
.com and the store I grew that
business from a $3 to a
$60 million business
in a five-year window.
I did it because of this.
If you really understand why
this is now become the thing
that I've attached myself to
that I say and how important it
is to you, everything
will change in your business.
And by the way, what I'm talking
about today and I think you know
it's funny to watch the
presidential election caught
people off guard in
the way that was marketed.
If you care about the nonprofit
that you're associated with.
If you care about helping your
school raise money or whatever
it is, what we are
living through my friends is the
greatest shift in communication
since the printing press.
The way we communicate, do
you understand that there are a
grown ass men in this
room that sent poop emoji's
via text last night?
(audience laughter)
You're, you this is
not high school now,
your parents are
living on these platforms.
Your mother is on
Facebook right this minute.
And you know
what's great about her?
She goes through it real slow.
Which lets me sell
to her even better.
The great, pssst, secret right
now for me is I'm converting
more dollars at 50 to
80-year-olds than I am from
20 to 30-year-olds on Facebook
because the speed in which they
go through the content.
The amount of you that
sit here and act one way.
You've got an Instagram account.
You're on Facebook.
You're debating if you should
get on Snapchat and then when
you've put on your business
hat and clothes and go into the
office you don't market that
way 'cause you don't think your
customers on it 'cause you
decided it's a young person
sport even
though your old, John,
is fascinating to me and that
dichotomy in 2017 world is
where all the opportunity it.
Attention is the
only thing that matters.
Why was I able to build
Wine Library with no money?
This is not a venture
capital based Instagram,
Snapchat, Facebook story.
This is a small business
in 1998 story with no money.
It was because I made every
penny that I spent work it's
face off and how did I do that?
Instead of doing direct mail
and some of the other things,
newspapers, and I did
all those things by the way.
Just so everybody
knows I did direct mail.
If anybody here,
anybody here from New Jersey?
Right, so you might've saw the
billboards that I put on the
Turnpike and 78.
Like I did everything but I
always created call to actions
to understand the ROI against
it 'cause I have the benefit of
being a retailer just like you.
This is easy.
You will know if these dollars
are effective because you
control the whole
funnel of the transaction.
When I work with Budweiser or
when I work with Under Armour,
they got so many different
behaviors going and they're not
selling it direct, it's
happening in other channels,
they don't know if it's TV or if
it's radio or if it's marketing
or promotions or Facebook.
You have that advantage
so here's what happened.
In 1997, I had a huge email
newsletter that I built by every
time anybody
walked into the wine shop,
I collected their email and
I built a huge 100,000+ person
email newsletter and I had
89.9% open rates because in 1997
nobody was sending email.
And so, what I was doing was
I was day trading attention.
In 1997, when there was only a
table of this size at the
North New Jersey Chamber of
Commerce event when I was like,
"Hey guys, the internet," while
they were spending money on
direct mail, I was
sending email at no cost.
It was free and I was selling
faster and more and people were
paying attention even though
not everybody was on email.
My friends, it doesn't matter if
you're on Instagram or Snapchat
or Facebook, it
matters that your customer is.
You don't get to decide on a
focus group of one that this is
the way that
everybody acts and is.
If you do not understand that
every penny you pour into this
platform to try to sell what
you sell is a higher ROI than
anything else you've done then
you are missing the absolute
opportunity in '17.
And let me
explain what that means.
The biggest fear I have
in this room is success.
I hate coming to these kind of
conferences where it's the best
of the bunch because
success, I love when people,
I'll do this whole thing and
they'll be spending all their
money on print or not at all.
I mean there's a lot of
people here who are first,
second, 10, 15,
20 years in business,
everybody here knows this
is a word-of-mouth business.
And I don't mean pools and spas.
I mean everything.
Word-of-mouth is the game.
What I'm stunned by is the
complete misunderstanding that
social media is the
current plumbing of
word-of-mouth in our society.
If you crush it for somebody and
you put in super nice and it's
all great and you're
unbelievable and you did
everything
perfect in your services,
how do people do you
think that person told in 1986?
In 1994? In 2001?
A couple of friends
when they came over?
Seven? Nine?
Do you know how many people they
now tell after they take one
picture and put it on
Facebook and Instagram.
Everybody they know.
And so, to me, I'm fascinated
because I've lived it.
This isn't, "Hey, I've invented
this thing Pinterest and
"you should use it."
This is we have no money.
We spent it on
email marketing in '97.
Then something
came out called Google.
The only time my dad fought me
in my career of something that
I wanted to do was Google.
Google comes out, it
starts doing better than Yahoo.
I'm fascinated by it and then
they start something called
AdWords, right?
At this point, you
all know what that is.
The day came out, I wanted to
buy the word "wine" on AdWords.
It was five cents
a click, minimum bid.
Nobody was on it yet.
I was there so I start
running it and it is crushing.
There's never been
anything close to it.
That run of 2001,
'02, '03 of Google AdWords,
I've never had better marketing
success other than what I'm
living through right now
on Facebook ads and
Instagram influencers doing
promotion right now.
That's why I'm
so loud right now.
If you've watch my career,
seems like a couple you on body
language have known
a little bit about me.
I was very quiet for the last
two or three years while I was
building VaynerMedia and doing
things so it was nothing crazy.
There was nothing that was so
blatantly underpriced if
you day trade attention.
Right now, that is
Facebook advertising.
That is Instagram influencers.
A mom in a neighborhood with
1,700 people that follow her on
Instagram that you could pay
$150 or give her free services
for and she gives
you a shout out and
you convert four people, that.
So to me, Google AdWords was
insane but my dad fought me
because he said to
me so it's working,
it's black and white.
I show him I go,
"I want to bet the farm."
The one thing that is great
about marketing is when you've
got the best hand,
you go pot committed.
So I wanted to go all-in on
Google Adwords and my dad was,
check this out, my dad didn't
want to do it 'cause he thought
our competitors would go
to Google and click our ads.
Like that's how
early it was back then.
And so, anyway,
luckily we did it.
We exploded and then my
career took a huge turn in 2006.
YouTube came out.
I thought it was
gonna be a big deal.
I started making a
wine show and this is,
I want to go into this phase
right now and this is where I'm
hopeful one or two of you really
latch onto and try to perform
this for yourselves because this
is my belief where there's the
most upside for your
business in the room.
Out of everything I just I just
got finished saying two minutes
ago that Facebook ads and
Instagram influencers are the
best arbitrage and the best buy
that I've seen in marketing in a
decade but what I'm about to go
into has the most upside for you
to transcend the
revenue of your business.
The problem is
it's extremely hard.
But here we go.
In 2006 YouTube
comes out, I go,
"Holy crap, this is a
huge," and I sit down
I start a show
called Wine Library TV.
I send when my
stock boys to Best Buy,
he buys a camera.
I sit down in my office.
I get the wine staff to pick me
some bottles of wine to taste
and I'm thinking that
I'm about to do QVC, right?
That's the
mentality I went in with.
If you're grew up in New Jersey,
I was really gonna go
Crazy Eddie meets QVC.
And so I'm ready, I'm pumped and
here we go and that camera goes
on and I realize, "Holy crap,
this is going to sit on the
"internet forever," and
literally like sometimes I look
back at episode one I can see,
'cause I know myself obviously,
I can see somewhere around a
minute or two in like uh-oh this
is not what I should do.
And right then and there, in the
first episode in the first five
minutes of something I went
on to do 1000 episodes of,
over four and a half,
five years,
I realized I needed to
become America's wine guy,
not a salesman for Wine Library.
And the reason it became his
huge phenomenon for 90% of you
that don't know it became a show
that hundreds of thousands of
people started watching a day
and I did five days a week and
the format was me
sitting at a table drinking
four bottles of wine.
(audience laughter)
By the way, best gig I ever had.
But what confused people,
as you can imagine,
what confused people was these
were wines that I had hundreds
of cases in stock of I would
pour it and taste it and would
tell people not to drink it.
Yeah, my staff was the same way.
Not to drink it.
That it reminded me of a
sheep taking a poop, right?
Or that it tasted like rubber or
that it was too sweet and it was
chaos internally
within my company.
But what I was doing was
I was building credibility.
And I was leveling up.
I don't want you to be
necessarily the consultant of
pool and spa services.
You could even
go into home decor.
go into landscaping.
You've got your skills
but if you are an extrovert,
if you are somebody who thinks
that they can feel comfortable
in front of the camera now I'm
gonna take it to another place.
I don't know how, how many of
you are now or in the last year
have actively listened
to a podcast of any sort?
Raise your hands.
Raise 'em high.
High, I want to see it.
Raise it high 'cause
I, actually do me a favor.
It's early and
it's good to get blood.
If you, all the
hands, stand up for a second.
I want people to
visually see this.
If you actively in the
last year listened to a
podcast of some sort.
So, don't sit yet,
I want to really watch this.
This is a very high percentage
of a room that again I think we
can all collectively agree, this
is not a 15-year-old teenage
girl aged crowd, right?
What's happened is
technology is changing.
Podcast, thank you for
standing, I appreciate it.
So podcasts is another place
where I want you to debate.
Here's where I'm actually going.
I am asking, I am
challenging this room
to debate this concept.
What would it look like
if you started a weekly show,
whether it was a
radio show on podcast,
whether it was a video show on
Facebook video and YouTube or
whether it was a weekly thing
that you wrote on Medium or
LinkedIn or Facebook, what would
happen if you didn't think of
yourselves as resellers and
retailers and service providers
but as a media
company, retailer?
Now, listen again, this is the
great advantage of coming from
exactly where you live.
If I walked in to my dad's
office in 2006 and pitched what
I just said
'cause it's what I lived,
he would've
punched me in the face.
He would've said I have no
idea what you're talking about.
This 10 years ago, 11 years of
right now everybody sitting in
saying what is this,
where is he going?
What does that mean?
What I know is the
following; all the attention,
all of it is going here.
What that means is distribution
has been commoditized.
No longer do you have to pay for
distribution if you can produce
the content that is effective.
It's smart to pay for
distribution on these platforms
but you don't have to.
It can happen organic.
You can get there and
you could spend some of
your money building it.
What also happens is your end
consumer starts latching onto
you at a higher level than
just the transaction that you're
trying to do with them.
And for anybody in this room and
I did my homework before I came
to do this talk, anybody in this
room who isn't trying to triple
down, 10X down, on being in
the service business above and
beyond after the first
transaction is just not running
a smart business as they can.
That is where all the economics
are in what you do for a living
and if you can actually use the
pool or spa as the gateway drug
to services
around the entire house,
let alone those two units,
that's when you start getting
into the economics that change
you from being a seven-figure
business into an
eight figure business.
Very honestly, by the
way, I just want everybody to
understand one thing
that's very important to me,
everything that
I talk about is hard.
Everything that I talk about
takes a crap load of work.
Everything I talk about takes
away from you watching entire
seasons of "House of Cards."
So if you sit in this room and
you've put in your 30 years and
you're happy with how much
money's in the bank and you're
feeling good and
you're a little tired,
you don't have to listen to me.
But if you want
more this is offense.
If you want more, this is
offense and I promise you here's
the part that
really makes me ponder.
Right now, it's offense.
In 2022, it's
going to be defense.
How many people here are
retiring in the next five years?
And I don't mean
you're gonna crush it and
retire and buy a boat.
I mean you're old
and you're finished?
(audience laughter)
Raise your hands high.
Respect.
Alright, so for the four
of you old dudes, respect.
Go fish.
(audience laughter)
For the 99.8% of
the rest of this room,
everything I'm
talking about right now,
if you have the audacity to own
your own business and live the
life that entrepreneurship and
owning your own
business allows you
and you do not put in the
hours over the next half decade
to educate yourself, I do not
want anybody running out of this
talk saying, "Wait
a minute, he's right.
"I'm in a letter 23-year-old
niece now do her thing."
This is not your outsourcing it
to that young buck and I know
that's why some of
you laughed, you're like,
"Yeah, Nancy gonna,"
no, no, not Nancy,
you John you're gonna do it.
If you own your business in this
room you need to spend 50 to 100
hours on the internet reading or
watching videos or listening,
I don't know how you learn but
you need to understand where
your end consumer's attention is
because you're not to be able to
reach them and
word-of-mouth, listen guys,
one more time.
Think about this,
this is so good.
I've actually never said this
publicly just literally came to
my head, you know how we're
talking about social norms?
You know you're talking
about how upset you are?
One of my favorite debates of
parents right now is they say
that their children aren't,
don't know how to be social.
They've decided,
parents in this room,
have decided that our children,
their children are socially
awkward because they
only live in the phone.
They've decided that the way
humans communicate is only
defined by looking somebody in
the eye and using their mouth.
They have been romantic in this
room about the platform that one
communicates through instead
of actually communicating.
Every child 8 to 12 to
17 in America right now
is dramatically
more social than you.
Because when you were 12 and
none of your friends were around
and it was 4:30 on a Tuesday you
went outside and threw a ball
against the wall.
(audience laughter)
You interacted with a
tire rapped to a tree.
So you may not like the way they
communicate but I promise you
they're the most
social that we've ever seen.
They're just using a
device and a platform that
we didn't have access to.
Some of you begged to have your
own phone line in your room so
you could be on the
phone with your girlfriend for
seven hours watching 90210.
Yes, I don't know how social
that was but here's what I know.
I know that the thing that
you're complaining about is
going to hurt your business
because as we continue to
communicate that way the way we
recommend products and service
will continue
to happen that way.
When 29-year-old Sally who's 17
or 19 or 21 right now is only
talking to her friends when they
first buy their or 41-year-old
Sally, I always try, I
want to remind everybody.
This is not 2008 anymore.
This is not what's coming.
This is what happened.
98% of the Fortune 500 CPG
brands in America declined last
year because they
continue to think the following,
watch this.
You really want to get
is the macro of all this.
How many people here now when
they watch television when you
watch your favorite TV
shows outside of live sports,
now watch them when you want to
watch them not when they air?
Netflix, DVR, TiVo,
on-demand, raise your hands.
High, high.
Great everybody, 90%.
How many of you fast-forward
every single commercial when
given the opportunity?
Raise your hands.
90% and even if the brands,
my brands that spend,
stick with me here,
collectively tens I think it's
now $80 billion to
make 30 second videos
and then air them in-between
shows that you
actually want to watch,
even if they're lucky enough to
have you have a chance to see
them because the remote
control falls off the bed.
(audience laughter)
Even if that miracle happens,
every person here the second
their favorite show goes into
commercial grabs this.
And this is where
the attention is
and that at a macro is what
I'm worried about you.
You're not, you are not like
Sonic restaurants or Toyota my
client in
spending on television.
You're spending
on something else.
But boy, is my intuition that
it's not being spent in the best
place that that dollar can be
spent or even more scary because
you've been so successful and
you were the king or queen of
that town you've gone completely
complacent and aren't spending
at all 'cause word-of-mouth is
in process which creates the
greatest vulnerability and
I promise you in
2022 and in 2024
it's not just the kid at the
table there was going to do it
better, it's also going to
be the macro discussion of,
you think Amazon
cares about your feelings?
You think Walmart spent
$20 billion buying e-commerce
sites so you can
sell pools and spas?
Where do you
think the world's going?
And so, if you are not planning
on retiring in the next five
years then you need to start
really understanding what's
happening because
I'm just talking about
simple social media right now.
How many people have
an Alexa in the home?
Raise your hand.
How many people have
an Alexa in their home?
An Echo, one more time.
Alexa Echo. Okay.
How many people don't
know what that is actually?
It's okay, I just
want to get a sense.
Great, man that guy in
the back there loves retiring,
loves not knowing anything.
I love that dude.
I just got to find him, yeah.
He's old school, huh?
I like that dude.
Alright, anyway.
(audience laughter)
Let me just give
you the average day for
somebody needs to have
their pool serviced in 2023.
Alexa, I want my pool serviced.
That's it.
And I'd think it be really smart
if you understood how social
media worked in 2017 so that
when you have to understand how
Alexa's algorithm works in 2020
that you're the answer to that
question not Amazon
itself or somebody else.
Guys, the
stakes are much higher.
Please do me a favor, please go
read what happened during the
Industrial Revolution and how
many people went out of business
out of complacency because they
didn't understand that we were
living through the biggest
technology shift of that era.
We are fully in it.
We're now in it and
so over the next decade,
I want to remind you that 10
years ago everything we live on
now didn't exist.
10, 10 years ago it's 11
for some of the websites,
10 years ago no smartphone.
10 years ago.
10 years ago,
YouTube's 11, Facebook's 11.
These are, if you
think a lot's happened
in the last 10 years
wait 'til you see what
happens over the next 10 years.
The stakes are enormously high
and I'm not here fear mongering.
This is just what's happening.
Very honestly, the fact that
you're the crème de la crème,
I assume that the
majority of people
in this room are like yes.
This is the opportunity.
This is where I transition from
a $6 million a year business to
$15 million a year business.
This is when I transition from
$180,000 a year business
to a $2.9 million
a year business.
This is pure opportunity.
The problem is and this is where
everybody defaults into they
raise their hand, Gary,
I didn't grow up with this.
Me neither, Carl.
(audience laughter)
I didn't grow up
with this either, Carl.
And guess what, Carl?
You didn't grow up
driving and you figured it out.
Understanding the digital
landscape and what our consumers
are doing on it is
now oxygen for businesses.
If you do not understand it,
you will be destroyed.
I've lived this.
I gave a keynote, so I
was an early investor in Uber.
I give a keynote at the limo and
taxi service thing and when they
announced me they said
Uber and a couple booed.
Half of them, just
like the Alexa thing didn't
even know it existed yet.
And I said, my friends, you have
to understand what this means.
And where I really went with the
talk and this is where I want to
go with you to bring you value
versus telling you a story,
here's my thesis.
My thesis is very simple, it is
far better to put yourself out
of business than to have
somebody else do it for you.
And what I mean by that is if
you know your vulnerability,
whatever you heard
here whatever you know,
well then you should
start doing that to curtail that
vulnerability and the reason I
want you to build a media brand
around you is no
technology, not Alexa,
not Facebook, not anything that
gets invented that we don't know
exist now, none of that builds
or beats brand because they're
not gonna ask Alexa for
"Let me service my pool
or who should I go with?"
They're gonna say I
want to go with David.
Call David and fix my pool.
And that's called brand.
And there's a
very big difference,
my friends,
between brand and sales.
And 90% of people are
in the sales business.
The direct mail
is a call to action,
it's a sale.
The Facebook stuff that
you've been doing and I did some
homework it's not
working 'cause you're selling.
You're not even
trying to romance a girl,
you're going right in.
(audience laughter)
How about making a video that's
instructional that can actually
help people to know what to do.
Now you've provided value.
I taught people how to
decant, this is very nerdy,
my decanting how to decant wine
video that was the gateway to
$1.7 million worth of sales.
It was very easy.
I watched it.
They'd go to YouTube, they'd
watch the decanting video.
They'd click WineLibrary.com
'cause it was linked below,
they'd go to the website
and they'd buy something.
When you provide
value upfront, you win.
I've written four New York Times
best selling books.
The one that is
sold the least is called
"The Thank You Economy."
It's the one
that matters the most.
And the reason it's sold
the least is 'cause nobody
wants to do the work.
When people are done
reading it they put down a say,
"Screw that."
They don't want to provide the
upfront value and all I'm trying
to do in my career is
provide the upright value.
Basically my entire thesis of
selling which was the next book
I wrote, "Jab, Jab, Jab, Right
Hook" is how do I guilt you
into buying my stuff?
How do I provide you so
much value that it would be
inconceivable to you
to go with somebody else.
And that is what I want to
challenge everybody here to
think about as a thesis and then
what I want to spend the next
55, 50 minutes I want to start
Q&amp;A pretty quickly so let me
frame up Q&amp;A.
I'll talk a little
bit then we'll get going,
then we'll see how Q&amp;A.
I want to go
very detail oriented.
When we go in to
Q&amp;A I want to be like,
"Hey Gary, Sal, own
two stores in Minnesota,
"you know, shops.
"We tried
Facebook, it didn't work."
Let's go very
deep like how I set up?
Is Snapchat worth it?
Go very, to me this is
the opportunity this is the
opportunity that this
organization has
created for you,
this is I think you
can go watch the first
30 minutes of this on YouTube.
What BioGuard did for you is
gave me enough time to do the
Q&amp;A so please ask me your
direct questions digitally.
What websites still matter?
How do you think about this?
Let me give you
some other things.
By the way, day trading
attention my most exciting
meeting is with a guy by name of
Bob Pittman tomorrow who started
MTV who owns iHeartRadio.
That's why I
asked about the podcast.
My belief is that drive time
radio is starting to get low
enough in cost that
it might be a deal again.
So I'm not digital-ist.
I'm an attention-ist.
I don't care where your
attention is if tomorrow I woke
up and Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
Snapchat, YouTube and LinkedIn
all disappeared I'd be pumped
because my contemporaries
would be confused and I would be
spending every minute figuring
out where everybody went.
And I would know for next
24 to 36 months it would be
underpriced because while people
debated if it's gonna stick
around or matter I'd be
executing and selling stuff.
So, that's the punchline.
Are we in a position, do
you think digitally first?
The answer is no for
85, 90% of this audience.
Are you, if you are,
for the other 15%,
are you complacent in the things
that got you here which was you
were just like me
and you won on Google?
And you won on Google Adwords
but now that's changing 'cause
that expense is going
higher and that's not branding
'cause that sales.
That's just blue letters.
Have you figured out how to
make two-minute and three-minute
videos and put them on
Facebook to drive your business.
Have you figured out how to
get home and
lifestyle Instagram accounts?
Paying them $100, $200 for a
shout out which then drives
conversion for you?
Have you figured out the new
arbitrages and inevitably
what are you gonna then
go and do about it?
Because the opportunity is real.
I believe for small businesses
in America you're on the clock.
When I gave this talk, a
very different version in 1999,
you know who's D-Day it was?
It was called bookstores.
They didn't know it but they
were done and then who was on
D-Day in 2009, '10, '11
cab and limo drivers.
Do you know how sad
it is personally for me?
As I told you
was born in Russia,
some of my dad's
friends went to LA and started,
you know, drove a
cab for 7, 8, 10 years.
Then eventually saved up all
the money and bought a couple of
cars and built their business.
Got to that age of 55, 56.
Had something of a business that
was worth something they were
about to sell it off and in 24
months Uber destroyed the value
of their business by 90%.
One of my dad's friends was
gonna sell his business for
$3.7 million decided not to
for another year or two and
sold for $370,000.
That's just real so
as we sit here today,
I promise you the Marriott
and the Hilton weren't sitting
around four
years ago and saying,
"What are our
threats in the future?"
I promise you nobody raised
their hand in that room and
said, "Hey, wait a minute what
if somebody invents a website
"that is like the eBay
of people's actual homes and
"instead of staying in hotels
"we would stay in
each other's homes?"
How many people here have
used an AirBnB or on AirBnB?
Raise your hands.
Raise them high.
I want people to look.
How many people here
don't know what AirBnB is?
I expect some, raise
your hand, it's okay.
It's okay, don't worry.
AirBnB stands for
air bed and breakfast.
It is a website where people
list their homes and apartments
when they're not there and other
people stay in people's homes.
That's what's hurting the hotel
industry and so you sit here
today and I just want you to
do good content on Facebook,
YouTube and Instagram 'cause
that's where the attention is
and I'm worried if there's some
kid that's Sally right now is
about to invent something that's
gonna really hurt you and so
that's why this is what I call
almost like digital fitness.
There's no way to run a marathon
if you haven't been on the
treadmill preparing for it.
The most important thing for
me for you to do Facebook and
Instagram and YouTube and
videos and content and podcasts,
the most important thing for me
is that it's getting you into
the mindset of that world in
case you really
need it in three or four years.
Right now, I'm sitting here
and talking to you about the
differences of you growing your
business next year 4% versus
growing it 18%.
I don't want to come back here
in four years and talk about the
difference between
you selling your business
for $3.7 million or $370,000.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
So who's got questions?
Great.
How many mic runners do we have?
One? Oh three, awesome.
Great, let's start
with this lovely lady here.
Thanks for having me guys.
Jesus, I go in
such a weird trance.
I feel like I'm just
like getting out of it.
Hey, what's your name?
- Hey, my name's Mallory.
- How are you Mallory?
- I'm from the
Chicagoland area
- [Gary] Little closer to your
mouth,
- So...
- A little closer.
- Closer?
- Yeah.
- OK one of my questions is,
where do you draw the line
on informational and
actually teaching someone
how to do something that
you're already trying to sell?
Like for our industry,
service is really big,
and I know our
owners have always worried
how much content
we put on social media
so that we're not
selling ourselves out.
- [Gary] If you don't do it
somebody else is gonna do it.
- Okay.
Okay.
- Guys, have you
been on the internet?
What do you think,
you're not gonna do it Mal,
and your homies
are not gonna do it?
What's gonna happen is some
entrepreneur's gonna do it
who works for one of your
companies, become the guy,
and then get all
the referral business
to come through him.
And then he's
holding, whoever has
the end consumer's
attention has the leverage.
So, give it away.
I would absolutely
give away milk to sell cows,
all day long, but
people don't wanna do that,
because they're
used to selling milk.
- [Mallory] Right.
- And that's why the guy
that comes along and
gives away the milk for free
kills all the other businesses.
And the problem for you
is there's no cost of entry
to giving away the information.
If I knew what the hell to do
with the stuff you guys do,
I could do it right now.
Luckily I don't
so please help me.
But you know...
- [Mallory] Okay.
- You know what I mean?
- [Mallory] That's always
been the work.
- And by the way,
just 'cause you're
now gonna tell them
'cause you met some
guy who wrote books,
they're not gonna believe you.
- [Mallory] No, I know.
- [Gary] They're not
gonna change.
That's why they're gonna lose,
'cause they deserve to lose.
It makes me happy
that they're gonna lose.
That, by the way,
that's capitalism!
Everybody loves
capitalism and business
when it's in your favor.
You loved it when
you outworked the old guy
that used to be in
town and took the business.
You don't like it
when it happens to you.
That's why I make fun
of all my crony 60 and 70
and 80 year old white Republican
homies that are my friends
who want to then, after
hustling and making money
want to change laws to
protect them, I'm like uh uh.
You're old now, you will die.
(audience laughter)
By the way, unless,
my business
partner's Stephen Ross,
he owns 30% of VaynerMedia,
he's my partner in my fund,
he owns the Miami Dolphins,
he's the biggest real
estate developer in America,
it's called Related,
he's worth $13 billion,
he's 76 years old, and
if I text him right now
and say hey, I just
found this weird shed in
Louisiana and I think
we can buy it for 100,000
and flip it into a
million dollar deal,
he'll text me back in one
minute, he loves the game.
It's not about the money,
loves the game.
And that's the way it is.
Question?
Hey man.
- Steven Metz Central Jersey
Pools, Freehold, New Jersey.
- [Gary] Awesome,
where do you live?
- Freehold.
- [Gary] Oh Freehold,
I didn't catch that.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Yeah that's awesome.
- So we've grown our Facebook
audience to a large number
but when we post videos--
- [Gary] Organic reach is dead.
- It's dead.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So, is there any
way to get around that?
- [Gary] Nope, pay.
- Just pay.
- [Gary] Just pay, and I'm
glad you asked that Steven
because that hurt so
many people's feelings.
I wanted to
remind all those people,
well you pay other places.
So what happened
was, it was funny.
If you check videos online I've
talked about this for years,
it's starting to correct itself.
That was huge for me,
and my selfish interests
because while
everybody was emotional
and saying that
Zuck screwed them,
I was spending money
'cause it was underpriced.
It's incredible, you
can target people that are
$250,000 household
income within five mile radius
of your office, and you
can pick other targeting.
The big thing though, so yes
pay, it's still under priced.
In two or three
years, five years,
it'll be like Google and
it'll be priced accordingly,
and then it's
gonna be like Google
in some categories, over priced.
But the key for you to really
think about is the content.
'Cause once you
get my attention,
like this keynote,
I have all your attention!
The framework has
been set for the attention.
If this talk sucked, nothing
good was gonna happen for me.
Right?
So really think
about the content,
back to
Mallory's question right?
What are you
actually putting out there?
Is it just
feature, feature, feature?
Testimonials.
You know like, oh let's talk
about the "Thank You Economy."
I want to challenge everybody
here, thank you my friend,
appreciate it,
continued success.
I want to challenge
everybody here to a concept.
I call it the Jay Cutler
thesis, let me explain.
(laughing) Some football fans.
So, I'm writing
the "Thank You Economy,"
it comes out in
2011, so in 2010,
I asked my order
department at WineLibrary.com to
search people's names on Google
with the word Twitter after it.
So, based on when
somebody orders something.
So if Sally Thompson
ordered something, every order.
There was two people
internally that went online
typed in Sally Thompson
Twitter, and that'd be hard
'cause there'd be
17 Sally Thompsons
could they figure out
if it's the right person?
Somebody like Gary
Vaynerchuk would've been great,
one of a kind name.
So we got some of those.
So we took some of those things
and then we
followed them on Twitter.
Want everybody to
pay attention to this
'cause this
really works on Facebook.
This is the reason I
want every single transaction
you make, that
you figure out a way
to be following
that person on Facebook.
Make it a business practice
that that's a prerequisite,
or you do something for them,
make that relationship,
here's why.
Not them follow you,
pay attention to how
much I reverse stuff.
You follow them, let me explain.
So we find this guy
who places a $287 order
for a case of
Pinot Grigio to Chicago.
And we find him online,
unique name they find him.
And every Tweet he puts
out is about Jay Cutler.
Jay Cutler you're the man.
Jay Cutler great pass.
Jay Cutler what the
(hums) you know,
Jay Cutler this,
Jay Cutler that,
Jay Cutler that.
So, I keep getting
presented while I'm traveling,
hey we found this,
this person's into surfing
but not really.
Oh we got somebody, this
guy's really into Jay Cutler.
I go great, go on eBay and
buy a Jay Cutler signed jersey
and send it to him
and write a note that says
thank you for your business
at Wine Library, that's it.
And the person on
the other line goes
but he only bought a
$270 thing and we made
$13 of profit, we're
a premium price leader.
I said uh huh.
He goes okay, so we
bought a $330 Jay Cutler jersey
and shipped it to
him signed, or 289.
And I'm pumped, I'm like this
person's gonna be blown away.
Right, they bought a
cocamanian case of Pino Grigio,
this is 2011,
right, he's gonna be like
how the hell did they even know?
I'm super pumped.
And we sent four or five
other things, little things
not as extravagant.
And some of those
people wrote back emails.
And this guy has not
written back for three weeks.
And I'm like where the hell
is this son of a bitch, right?
(audience laughter)
And so I'm waiting and
I'm waiting and I'm waiting,
and finally I'm
about to board a plane
and I get a phone call and
they said, big, we got 'em.
I'm like great.
I'm like what did he do?
They go, it's actually
a little bit different.
I'm like go ahead.
They're like, we just
got a $4,800 burgundy order
from Plano, Texas.
I'm like great.
What do you mean?
They go let us read
you the note in the order.
Hey Wine Library, first of
all, great burgundy selection.
This is insane, your
prices are incredible.
Can you hold the order
'cause it's a little hot
right now in Texas, can
you ship it in the fall?
P.S., you sent my friend John
a Jay Cutler jersey,
that's how I became
aware of your website.
P.S.S.,
I'm a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan.
(audience laughter)
If your company,
whether it's you or an intern
or a junior employee, is
following every single person
that you've ever sold a
pool or spa or servicing
on Facebook, and they
see that that wife posts
that it's the first
day of nursery school
for their daughter
Charlotte, and you go
and send that person to Target
and buy some nice flowers
or gifts and bring it
to them and say congrats.
Or you call them
on their birthday.
Or you realize
they're a big sports fan
and their team's
playing in the playoffs.
They're a Dolphins fan and
they're playing in the playoffs
for the first time in
15 years in the playoffs,
and you send them the
chicken wings and catering
and say thank you
for their business.
That word of mouth
will change your business.
Because I'm a
salesman and I know
that after we make the sale,
we go hunting for the next one.
And I know that in 1996,
when you do something like that,
that those people
would always talk about you
and tell that story.
I know in 2017, those people
are gonna take four pictures
and put them on nine websites
and everybody in your town will
know that you're a business
with a little bit more
soul than the ability to fix
or sell them that
product or service.
This is the effort and the
uniqueness of using social media
and digital media as a gateway
to create human interaction.
I use this as the first step
in my chess match
to shake your hand.
Do you understand?
So many of you think
this is replacing something,
when you don't
realize it became the gateway
to the next thing.
10 years ago, it was super
weird to be dating somebody
you met on the internet.
Today, every 20-year-old I know
swipes to the right and left
20 hours a day.
So social norms change.
There was a time
when Elvis shook his hips
and grandmas and
moms all over this country
thought he was the devil.
Have you seen what
people are posting on Instagram?
(audience laughter)
Questions?
There's one over here,
one over here.
It's a race.
Okay, people are very close.
Alright.
- [Travis] So with all the
information--
- What's your name?
- [Travis] Travis Hogan.
- Travis.
- [Travis] Fiesta Pools.
So where do you start?
You name so
many different things.
Do you go home with content and
you have to make it relevant
that people want to watch
or else you're just like
every other person--
- [Gary] So, Trav,
let's start from the beginning.
Keep, stay up.
We'll use you to
really bring a ton of value.
- [Travis] Great.
(audience laughter)
- So Trav,
what are you doing now?
Anything?
- We've done some Facebook ads.
I mean, to be honest,
not a whole lot.
But we've done a few things.
So, Facebook ads,
we're doing Google ads.
- [Gary] How much?
- 1,500 a month in
AdWords on Google
and 500 on Facebook.
- [Gary] And
what else do you do?
- We do some print.
- [Gary] How much?
- Media direct.
Probably 10,000 a year.
Just in print.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Other, word of mouth
is where we get a lot...
- [Gary] So how much marketing
dollars do you spend a year,
you think?
- Probably 40,000, 50,000.
- And so the
rest is word of mouth.
That's really
driving the business, right?
- [Travis] Correct.
- So look, very honestly, man?
Trav, I think
first and foremost,
how many customers
have you had in the history
of your business?
- Say it again, I'm sorry.
- [Gary] How many customers
have you had in the history
of your business?
- Probably 10,000.
- [Gary] Do you have the data?
- A lot of it, yes.
- [Gary] Yeah, I would really,
really latch on to the
last thing I just did.
First of all, with
that limited a budget,
I wanna
maximize sweat, not cash.
So let's go back and
look at those 10,000 people.
If I bought into your business
and I was a new partner,
obviously you'd be like "Hey,
Gary, you do the marketing."
I'm like "No shit, Trav."
(Travis and audience laughter)
- Yes.
- So I would say of the 50,000,
I'd probably spend 15,000
on thank you economy, right?
I'd probably get an intern,
because people always
want to work and learn.
Intern to do
Facebook and Twitter data.
You'll find
somebody, if you try.
An intern, very
low cost, to reach out
and follow all 10,000 people.
All of them, I mean it.
It's gonna take
the whole summer.
- [Travis] So do
you friend them?
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
- Alright.
- [Gary] And you friend
them as your business,
so you have to have a
business page, not you.
- [Travis] Yeah, got it.
- 'Cause, I mean, what's Trav
up to, you know what I mean?
And so--
- [Travis] (laughs)
Hashtag creepy?
- Yeah.
(audience laughter)
Can you zoom in on the beard?
And so of those 10,000,
847 will accept your friendship.
First of all, of those 10,000,
6,900 are still
there inactive, so 894.
And those 894...
And probably
work backwards, right?
I would attack heavily
everybody in the last 18 months,
because it's still fresh.
How long you been in business?
- 60 years.
- [Gary] Jesus.
- Yeah, I had to stop and think.
- Yeah.
Let me reframe it,
let's restructure.
The last two years,
every customer,
follow them on Facebook
and then spend $10,000
on surprise and delight.
You know?
The other thing you can
do while they're doing that
is you should go to
every local business in town
and try to make biz dev deals.
Be like, you go to a
local business, the barber,
and be like "Listen, I know
this is gonna sound weird.
"I was in Louisiana
and there's this weird guy,
"he gave a talk and he made
me do this, so bear with me.
"I want to surprise some of
my clients with your services.
"I think this could be a
great word of mouth for you.
"Are you willing to
give me five free haircuts?"
Let me save you time.
He or she's gonna say yes.
So now all of a sudden,
we're gonna get $40,000 worth
of services for, you might
not even have to spend 10,000.
Remember when I said
what I talk about is hard?
This is the
"House of Cards" part.
"Call of Duty" part.
This is the you want
your business to grow
but you're on four
goddamn softball teams.
Right?
So this is what I would do.
The rest, then, I would
do is reach out to people
in your community
that are making content.
So it's searched on
Twitter, Facebook, and YouTube
of young kids and other actors.
Where do you live?
- Tulsa.
- Great. Plenty,
plenty of content producers.
See if some of them
want to make the funny videos
or the interesting videos.
Drive the costs down.
And then I would
save the last $30,000,
20,000 of it on Facebook
ads against that content
in the local area, against
high net worth individuals
that can afford the
products and services.
- [Travis] Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it.
- Yeah.
- [Peter] So, I
work for BioLab as well.
- Great.
- What role can we--
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Peter.
- [Gary] Peter.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you man.
- What role can we play to
help Travis and all the other
dealers do that,
because we have scale, right?
We should be able to help them
venture into these channels.
- [Gary] You know it's funny,
we were talking back stage.
Vayner, my company,
we've gone from
zero to 100 million
in revenue in six years.
What happened is, now we're
only able to work with the
biggest companies in the world
because we're
fancy and expensive.
Over the holiday,
I'm like, "This sucks."
I want to help
people that I'm like,
so I've spent
the last six months,
and we're just
about to roll it out,
of a program that is
somewhere in the ballpark of
$350,000 to
$400,000 a year, you know.
I want to start
working with more companies
that look like you guys
because if you then start
doing better actions like this
with your marketing dollars
then you can start using them
as case studies to show them
and I want to make you do
the scaling the un-scalable.
We have to remember,
what you're doing
they may not
have the budget for,
so it's not that I
want the 350 for anything
other than amplification.
We're still going to do the
same kind of stuff as well,
but I think the
number one, it's parenting.
The best way to parent
is set an actual example.
- [Peter] Good deal, thank you.
- Cool.
My friend, oh hey, how are you?
- [Angela] Good.
- What's your name?
- Angela.
- [Angela] From
upstate New York.
- Awesome.
- Our biggest social
media concern is reviews.
- [Gary] That's not a
concern, it's uncontrollable.
- Right.
- [Gary] Go to
Glassdoor right now
and everybody I've
ever fired at VaynerMedia
says I'm the worst piece
of crap they've ever met.
- Right, so how do you respond?
- [Gary] I don't.
- You just leave it blank?
- Because anybody who's smart
in the world, especially
if they're going to buy
a product and
service that costs something
is going to take an anonymous
review with a grain of salt.
So how do I do it?
I think that most people when
they think about reviews,
become ostriches and
put their head in the sand.
What I try to do is become
Loyola Marymount
basketball 1992.
I know that's very nerdy.
I'm trying to win
the game 147 to 132.
The biggest reason
you need to get louder
is if you don't get loud,
somebody else is
going to be loud for you.
- [Angela] Okay.
- [Gary] I can leave
a negative review for
every one of you right now.
- [Angela] Alright,
that's it then.
(audience laughter)
- So, you know, I'm
doing that for effect
because it was funny,
but the real punchline is
people are going
to leave reviews.
What do you think,
just by not being active
on the internet, people are
just going to not write reviews?
People have written reviews.
So what's the punchline here?
- [Man] Should you
be pushing people
to review you though?
- I mean, I think when
you do the right ac,
I think when you buy
somebody chicken wings
to watch a football game,
they might leave a review.
- [Man] For sure.
- You know, I think
whenever you ask for something
it's not as pure as if
it would have happened.
Sure, again, this is the
beauty of having retention.
This is why again,
I'm a businessman,
I happen to be
good at marketing.
If you're not deploying
services on top of your sales,
it's just not smart.
You're leaving so
much money on the table.
So first, I would do that
and then I would find ways
to be in touch with those
people as often as possible
and then not just when you're
asking them for goddamn money.
You're super in
touch when you want cash.
How about when something
big in their life happened?
How about actually
building a relationship?
My friends, as
we go more Jetsons,
the people that act like the
Flintstones are going to win.
Your grandparents
are more theoretically
prepared for
social media than you are,
because they
invented the baker's dozen.
They invented when
you walked into the shop
they started
cutting your roast beef
because they knew who you were.
They invented
coming over your house
and giving you a cake
when your grandmother died.
Now you have technology
and you can scale that.
Can we please deploy some soul
and scale it?
My friend back there?
Yes, let's get him a mic.
- How are you, my friend?
- Pretty good, Russ Michael,
DMV Pools, New York.
- [Gary] Very Nice.
- Two-part question.
- [Gary] Please.
- Blogs.
- [Gary] Blogs.
- They were very big.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But you're pushing video.
- [Gary] I am.
- Okay.
- MASH used to be the
number one show on television.
- [Russ] Okay.
(audience laughter)
Regarding content on the videos.
Lots of our
vendors are producing them.
You're saying to
do it on your own.
- [Gary] Correct.
- Home-grown, ignore that.
- [Gary] Yes, I mean,
you don't ignore it.
Maybe when you
get really to a scale
where you may have a
video person that knows
what to do with it,
maybe they can take that,
edit pieces out, but if you're
putting out the same content
that everybody else is putting
out, 'cause you're all lazy,
and you're just
pushing republish,
you're not
differentiating yourself.
- [Russ] Okay,
all right, thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
More of that, please, by the
way, that was super helpful.
It's very unusual for me to
have this much Q&amp;A time.
It's a great way for
me to start the year.
By the way, I audited a lot
of the businesses in here.
Nobody should be
shy, you all suck.
(audience laughter)
Hey.
- James Robyn from Rin
Robyn Pools in New Jersey.
- [Gary] Where?
- Bernardsville
and Hackettstown.
- [Gary] Very cool, my
sister lives in Basking Ridge.
- Great.
- [Gary] Let's make a deal.
- [James] Does she have a pool?
- No, she's got a townhouse.
- Does she want a pool?
- [Gary] She does, but she
needs to hustle a little more.
- Okay, not
directly in social media,
but I'm sure everybody in
this room has been approached
by folks like
HomeAdvisor and Angie's List.
- [Gary] Sure.
- I have my opinion,
I'm interested in yours.
- I think that they
are taking advantage
of your lack of knowledge,
and are arbitraging you
out of your own customer,
and are sitting in the middle,
and eventually will
have tons of leverage,
and will cut into your margin.
And so I think you're all
collectively digitally lazy,
and so you're
giving away the real value.
What do you think?
- Oh, I think they're
a total rip-off, yeah.
- So what I want is--
- [James] I would
not participate at all.
- And I don't think they're
a total rip-off, I don't.
You know, I have empathy for
why you would think that,
I just think, Jesus,
you own your own business.
Why don't you work harder,
understand what you have to do,
to not rely on that drug.
That's how I feel about Google.
What do you think
Google's gonna do?
You think Google cares about
your business in Bernardsville?
I think this is
ridiculous, what we're doing.
We have an
opportunity to build our brand.
The reason I want your content
is, I wanna see your face.
Or, whoever you decide, right?
The thing that
is not commoditize-able,
that's the key.
So absolutely, they're
arbing you in-between.
Do you know how OpenTable
built its restaurant business?
They took advantage of
restaurant, they make money.
The reason they charge
one dollar, so OpenTable,
has anybody used OpenTable
to book a restaurant, great.
OpenTable charges those
restaurants a dollar
when you book.
Right, but it costs them 90
cents to get you on Google.
It's their customer,
it's their customer.
You Googled one tree
restaurant to book it,
but because a
OpenTable ad shows up first,
you booked it through OpenTable.
So they became a toll
booth for their customer.
Are you kidding me?
I'm pissed.
(audience laughter)
So that's the scoop there.
Questions?
Let's do it,
let's keep this goin'.
By the way, as I'm thinking,
before we get this
question, Twitter search.
If you wanna write down
something very fascinating,
if you go to twitter.com/search,
you can search pool terms,
home terms, the words,
putting in a pool,
sentences even, the word pool,
and then you can search
within a five or 10-mile
radius of your zip code
and then you can see everything
people are saying about,
literally, people
will say things like,
thinking about
putting in a pool this year.
This is the
world we live in now.
They will actually tweet that.
Now, remember
what I said earlier.
Don't do the
17-year-old dude move.
Don't just jump in
and be like, I sell pools.
Right, romance
the girl a little bit.
Try to provide them value.
What kind, do you
have the yard structure?
You know, some of those things
that you give away for free.
Then they trust, and
you become the person
that they decide to go with.
So twitter.com/search, search
the terms that you guys know
from a maintenance,
I'm not an expert,
I'm sure there's terms
for some of the pipes
and different things,
not just the word, pool,
'cause you get a lot of
things like, in the pool,
and that's not gonna
do you anything, right?
Search within your mile radius,
so that's the advanced search.
When you search
terms, you'll get results,
you'll see an advanced
search in there, you know,
put in your zip code,
put in a mile radius,
and then just read
what people are saying.
This is no different than if
you were sitting at the
park and somebody was talking
and saying, yeah,
thinking about getting a pool.
And you be like,
excuse me, you know.
And on Twitter, it's accepted.
Creeper, on Facebook.
On Twitter, it's an
open forum, so it's accepted.
So you jumping in,
just have the right
cadence to bring value first.
They're gonna know what
you are, they're gonna look
at your profile and
know that you sell it.
You don't have to tell 'em,
you're wearing the t-shirt.
- Yes, hey, man.
What's your name?
- [Mark] Hi, my name's Mark,
I'm from Nova Scotia, Canada.
- Very nice.
- With the video content,
what have you learned in terms
of the length of
content that's applicable?
Are you lookin'
for a 30-second teaser,
that then gets
into three minutes?
What's the target
in terms of length?
- [Gary] It's a great question,
thank you.
So, the conventional
wisdom in my world,
it's seems like
you're asking a question
with a little bit of data,
is shorter is better,
and I don't believe that.
So, I believe that if
Stars Wars' next film came out
and it was seven
hours and 13 seconds,
people would watch it.
And I know that when
Vine was hot for six seconds,
I looked at data
that showed plenty
of people would stop
watching after three.
So, I would say, whatever
message you're trying to say,
that's the beauty of
it not being a commercial,
where you bought 30
seconds worth of time.
If what you have to say is gonna
take 16 seconds, mazel tov.
If it's gonna take four
minutes and 10 seconds, great.
So, I have videos on
Facebook that do extremely well
that are an
hour and a half long,
but no question, when
I can find those moments
for a minute or two,
there's absolutely
a little bit more upside
in the one to two minutes.
But those 60 minute keynotes
are very valuable, too.
So, it just depends,
and I would say,
you should produce enough
content that does all things,
and you'll learn
what works for you.
Video, look,
nothing has changed.
Human behavior is just
adjusting to new platforms.
TV and movie stars were
always bigger than authors.
So, if you can do video,
it's real powerful.
- [Mark] Great, thanks.
- You got it.
Questions? Very
good, here we go.
Yes.
Hey, man.
- [Bob] Bob Davis from Virginia.
- Hey, Bob.
- I'm wondering, a lot of
the information that I've,
a lot of what I've seen from
you is a lot of brief stuff.
- [Gary] On Facebook?
- Yeah, I've listened to you
for about four or five years.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Anyway,
what's the
future of the website?
- [Gary] That's a good question.
I still think you need
a home on the internet,
so I'm pretty
bullish on the website still.
I'm just sad when
I meet new businesses,
or talk to friends
or small businesses,
or even corporations
that overspend on the website.
So, to me, thinking about
the businesses in this room,
I think with
Squarespace and WordPress like
for what you actually do, you
could really honestly get away
with probably between
five and 25,000 all in
and be in an amazing place,
probably even less in some ways.
So, I do think that
you don't ever want to,
just like in Angie's List,
I don't wanna be at the mercy
of Facebook, or Instagram,
or Snapchat, or Youtube,
but I wanna extract the value
of attention while I'm there.
And I wanna push them to my
brand, first and foremost,
so that it's remembered, but
the website is a good place
to collect data to
put out the information.
But it is stunning
to watch how many people
now are making a
decision on business.
The amount of people
in this room, my friend,
who've lost
business last season,
because their Instagram and
Facebook seem like crickets
or they were out of
business, is stunning.
It is becoming the
place that people go first
to make decisions,
not just the website.
But I do not
believe the website is dead,
I still think it
needs to be maintained.
If people here have a website
that they built
11, 12 years ago,
it'd probably be
smart to refresh it
a little bit to feel relevant.
I think it's more
of a branding thing.
And from a
functionality standpoint,
a Facebook ad that has
your phone number in it
that you spend $5,000 a year
on is gonna do a lot more
than the phone
number on your website.
So, I'm still into it,
but it's clearly,
it's an evolving
thing, but I do believe
there's still value in it.
Do you have any
followup for that?
- [Bob] Well, it seems like the
biggest activity that we get
on our website is
people will call and say,
"Hey, I read what
you wrote about a pool
"or a hot tub or something."
I was in the
store the other day,
and a guy
actually told me, he said,
"Yeah, I read what you wrote
on the website about hot tubs."
I was like, "That's cool."
- [Gary] It's real, man.
- Yeah, and so I think--
- [Gary] You know, to me,
literally, if like we
were jammin'
together, I'd be like,
"Hey, let's make the
phone number bigger."
It's amazing
some of these things,
these subtle little tweaks,
but I agree with you.
You know, even
before you said that,
notice how I used the
phone number, Facebook ad.
I just know what's going,
I see it, it's not I'm genius,
I'm putting in the
work 18 hours a day
to watch the behavior of
consumers on the internet.
So, yeah, I would triple
down on the phone number.
And then you
know what I would do,
who's getting the phone calls?
- Well, we have different
phone numbers on the site,
but my name is by my cell phone.
As long as somebody doesn't
call me yellin' and screamin',
cussin' mad, I'll talk
to anyone anytime of day.
And the truth is,
I rarely get called.
But when I do get called, it's
usually for something good.
But listening to
you standing here,
it occurs to me that probably
one of the greatest values
or the best uses of my website
could be to tell the story.
Because sales
happen from a good story.
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- And then inform
people about our people
and tell a few
stories about that.
- [Gary] You beat me to it.
What I would have done,
my website--
- [Bob] Rah rah.
- I would have a phone
number, I would have two
or three videos, and
then what I would make
in that video is I
would reverse engineer
the biggest themes
of the phone calls.
So, the reason I was asking
you who gets the phone calls,
I'd love to know by breakdown,
like having them
start documenting
the content of the phone call.
Because that,
I think, is so valuable
because then you
just reverse engineer
what they're
actually looking for.
And if you're seeing
seven out of 11 calls focusing
in on this, you
storytell against that.
- [Bob] Thanks.
- You got it, brother.
Questions?
Oh, great.
Stand up.
- [Kara] Okay.
- What's your name?
- [Kara] I'm Kara.
- Kara.
- [Kara] Wichita, Kansas.
- Very nice.
- We do Facebook,
Twitter, and all of that
but we haven't
done an Instagram yet
and I think.
Do you normally for a
business just feature products
or how do you get started in?
- [Gary] Yeah, so you should A,
definitely do Instagram.
- [Kara] Yeah.
- So much of the
decision maker in the home
that's making decisions for
your products and services
is starting to live there.
So, here's what I would do.
I would go to Instagram.
Do you
personally have Instagram?
- [Kara] I do
but I don't use it.
- Okay, open it,
resign in if you
have to whatever.
There's a search function.
You know what a hashtag is
from Twitter?
- [Kara] Yes.
- Search hashtags,
take the six most
important terms in your world,
pool, spa,
and then again I'm
not educated enough
I want you to get
into those second.
It's not wine,
it's Pinot Noir,
it's Bordeaux,
it's Silicon Valley,
Sonoma Valley.
You guys know those terms.
Search those terms on Instagram.
I want you to spend
between five and 10 hours,
while you're on the flight,
walking down whatever.
It doesn't have to
come in prime time.
Chip away in inefficient times.
And I want you to
search those hashtags
and look at all the
content that's being produced.
Click into the content,
look at the engagement,
look at the comments,
and you get an audit and a feel.
And you're like oh wow,
these kind of
photos are over indexing
across the entire
Instagram ecosystem.
It seems like when
people take photos of their pool
at sunset people get like really
like you'll pick up
on some action shots
or one minute tutorials
of how to fix it instead of
back to that.
So, put in the work.
- [Kara] Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Kara] Thank you.
- Yeah.
Questions?
My man's back over here.
Let's,
we'll get to
second time over there.
Somebody over here?
One more time
raise your hand for me?
Okay, just one.
Got it.
Great.
- [Josh] I'm Josh from
Grand Rapids, Michigan.
- Hey, Josh.
- How do you find
Instagram influencers
for neighborhoods and markets?
- [Gary] You search again.
Hold the mic in
case there's a followup.
You search,
you search by count.
So, you go into search
and you can
search every single photo
that was posted in
Grand Rapids, Michigan.
And the first 12
photos are the top posts
and underneath that
are the most recent.
So, you search your zip code.
You click the first photo.
The amount of hand-to-hand
combat this is
that people don't want to do,
it's like sit ups.
We all known what sit ups do.
They do good things,
we just don't want to do them.
So, you have to do this work.
You have to go and search.
You click.
The first one's a
42 year old female
that has 1400 followers.
You look at her content.
She seems to be
like a trendy mom.
You hit the upper right hand
corner and send her a message
and say to her we
think you're an influencer.
We'd love to have
you post about our,
you go right there.
I'm comfortable going
in right for the hook.
You say look we
love your profile.
We'd love for you to give
a shout out to our service.
But this is where
you deploy some empathy.
Are you aware of our service?
Do you care about that stuff?
If you are,
we'd love to do a
business transaction with you.
The reason I want you
to do business transaction,
these smaller influencers,
they're not
even expecting money.
If they happen to have a pool
just you go and
checking out everything.
Or like who knows?
Whatever like
light weight supplies?
And by the way,
sometimes just by bragging
that a business
reached out to them
and thought their
Instagram was cool enough
to give a shout out.
So you just do that at scale.
Other people will surprise you.
You'll listen to me.
You'll do three of these.
You'll be pumped you're
getting some shout outs.
You do the fourth one
and she's like I
want $18,000 for a post.
You know?
So, you've go
to learn that game.
But that's how you do it,
hand-to-hand combat.
- [Josh] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Yes, sir?
- [Man] Question,
clearly content is king.
Many of us have,
"Click here to get our free
"pool building guide.
"Click here to get our
free spa buying guide."
You're saying to cut
that up into little pieces
and turn 'em into videos?
- [Gary] I do, I do.
I assume you're
using that as a gateway
to get the information to get--
- [Man] Capture, yeah,
putting in your email address
and then, bam, out it goes.
Then it's a trickle thing--
- [Gary] Of course,
it's a funnel.
- First five ideas on
things you need to know,
the next five things
that you need to know.
So, you're saying to
turn everything into a video?
- [Gary] Yes, I'm saying that
one of those five ideas
in a minute, 37 second
video on Facebook,
on Memorial Day
weekend gets shared enough
to change your business way more
than that funnel will ever do.
- [Man] Thank you.
- You got it.
Hey, what's your name?
- Megan Spillers, I'm from
Champaign-Urbana in Illinois.
My question is
regarding Snapchat.
I'm just, kind of,
wondering your opinion
on the format
since it's pictures,
10 second videos at max.
I use it to send pictures
to my friends, cool places,
all the places I went
last night in the city.
How can you
connect as a business?
Are you just trying
to be forefront of mind?
Are you trying to get in touch
with influencers on Snapchat?
How can you utilize that?
- [Gary] As somebody who
invested five million dollars
into Snapchat several years ago,
I'm very
bullish on the platform.
I thought it was
was the first platform
that came along that could
really bring Facebook
a challenge
because it had won
the entire, at the time,
13 to 22-year-old demo.
It's an
incredibly powerful tool.
The reason I didn't
bring it up a lot here
versus the last talk I gave,
I spent 80% of my time on it
because the people in
the room were marketing
to 15 to 25-year-olds,
is my concern is that
the demo is still too young.
In 2007, when I was
talking about Facebook
I wasn't necessarily
talking to companies
that were marketing to
70-year-olds.
Today, you heard
me talk about 50 to 70
being my favorite demo.
I'm helping a a
startup that goes after people
that are going
to retirement homes.
Their number one
conversion is Facebook,
targeting 50 and
60-year-olds of people
who have parents that are
70 and 80 and 90-year-olds.
So I think Snapchat's amazing.
I think it's got
a ton of work to do.
As you know
Instagram has copied almost
all their features over the
last three to four months,
which has slowed down some
of the growth for Snapchat.
They've obviously got spectacles
and that's a whole
'nother thing of AR and VR
and live streaming.
I don't think that
Snapchat, today at this moment,
is the craziest, most
important thing for this room.
But, back to me
saying get on the treadmill
before running the marathon,
do I believe
every single person here
should download
Snapchat and figure it out?
I do.
I know that seems
insane for so many of them.
How many people
here are now on Snapchat?
Raise your hand.
A year ago this
would've been three hands.
It would've been three.
What nobody realizes
is we're living in a world
where everybody's
living a younger life
than their parents did.
The younger
generation's dragging you down.
If you want to
talk to your daughter,
you gotta get on Snapchat,
that's where she's
spending 83% of her time
so you're gonna be there.
It's an important platform.
Filters are super fascinating.
The fact that people
here can buy a filter
for a hundred
bucks around the radius
of the most
important park in town,
that they may bring awareness,
I think is, kind of, cool.
I think in a year that would
be the strategy I'd probably do
which is buy a filter.
The way filters work is,
if you've been on Snapchat,
I know a lot of you haven't
but it seems like a lot have,
you take a
picture and you can swipe
and get these little filters.
As a small business,
you can buy a filter.
I see University of Kentucky,
you could buy a
filter over Rupp Arena,
one day, for 500 bucks,
and then
everybody becomes aware.
They're like, "What is this?"
And you have to be smart,
how do you make a
basketball and pool
you gotta be creative.
But, that's branding,
that's less funnel,
and less conversion,
that's more branding.
Once something
has all the attention,
if I want to sell
something right now
to a 17-year-old in America,
I'm only spending my
money on Instagram and Snapchat
not a penny anywhere else.
That 17-year-old
becomes 27 very quickly.
You got it.
Back there, yup, got 'em.
This is fun.
- [Nick] Absolute pleasure,
thank you very much.
My name's Nick, I'm
from Toronto, Ontario.
I'd like to get your
input on augmented reality
and where it's going.
- [Gary] It's gonna happen.
How many people played
Pokemon GO, raise your hands?
Raise it high.
It's a good number.
So, prior to Pokemon Go, zero
hands, augmented reality,
we will be seeing things.
You wanna really get
into black and white?
The reason I
won't give this advice
is because this would
cost $150,000 to build
and I don't think that's
practical for the high-risk,
low-reward chance
of pulling this off,
but this is a perfect
example of how Angie's List
or, remember when I said put
yourself out of business?
If somebody here's
big enough to do this,
you should debate this.
What if you built the app
that looked at your backyard
like this, and helped
them put the size of the pool
that they should put in,
and then that app,
because it's a utility,
was a gateway for your service?
So what I just
said is gonna happen.
People are gonna go
into their backyard,
they're gonna pull out their
phone, they're gonna point it,
they're gonna see their backyard
as if they were taking a photo,
but they're gonna do that
through the app
called Pool Locator.
And it's going to do
whatever the hell you guys do
for a living and figure out
that he needs to cut that tree
and the app would
eliminate that tree
and would show him
the options of the pool,
and then he would
say, "I like that,"
he would press a button,
she would press a button,
and you would be
the person that does it.
And as you think,
if you make the utility
and get tens and
thousands and hundreds,
and then you could not only
service Grand Rapids, Michigan,
but then you could
refer all the leads,
'cause the app was big,
to all the other people
in this room and
make 20% referral fee
through having the biggest
app of how people now decide
where they're gonna put a pool.
That's what I
think's gonna happen.
That was cool, actually.
That was a good idea.
Somebody should do that.
(audience laughter)
Yep, over there, yep.
Oh, oh, great, yeah,
let's get on this side.
- [Kathy] Hi, Kathy
from Aqua-Tech
in Winnipeg, Manitoba, Canada.
Just wanted to find out if
you could help me prioritize
in the exact
order that you think
I should be spending my time.
Right now we do a lot of
email marketing, primarily,
so my marching orders, when
I go home, should be what?
- [Gary] How's email doing?
- Fabulous.
- And so explain that in detail.
You're collecting emails somehow
and then you're
marketing against it?
- [Kathy] Correct.
- Yeah.
The thing that will
probably excite you the most
in the quickest period of time,
because the vulnerability is
the first six months or year
when it's not working as
well 'cause you don't have
all the expertise, is Facebook.
Facebook is the
closest thing to email
in the marketing
realm right now.
So how are you collecting email?
- [Kathy] With every water test
and every transaction.
- [Gary] Got it.
And then you're
remarketing for services?
- [Kathy] Correct.
- So it's more of a farming
mechanism than a hunting?
- [Kathy] Correct.
- Got it.
So, I think email and text
messaging, and following them
on Facebook and
surprising them--
- [Kathy] That's a kick butt
idea.
- And I knew you would like that
because you like email because
it's a retention vehicle.
So let's talk about the
hunting, instead of the farming.
How are you getting clients?
- Our website, primarily.
We've spent a lot of time and
effort into Google ratings,
so I think that we should
stop half, and maybe--
- [Gary] I don't
think you should,
by the way, it's never like,
people still look at billboards.
Do I think they're as
valuable as they used to be?
They can't be, because
every passenger's looking
at their phone, and
those are lost eyeballs.
(audience laughter)
So, it's not that
you should stop that,
but back to having so
much time, money, and energy.
Facebook.
You have to
understand what Facebook is.
Facebook is direct response
sales and branding.
You can do both.
Whereas Google
and Google reviews
it's all black and white,
it's all blue,
actually, blue, right?
It's not building brand.
These videos that I'm
desperate, and by the way,
are you guys
completely blown away as I am,
the quality of
video from just this?
You don't need to
hire DRock. Sorry, DRock.
(audience laughter)
This!
And the other thing is, every
single 17-year-old in America
knows what to do.
So you've unlimited
kids in Winnipeg or Toronto
that are willing to do
it for minimal or free.
More video content on
Facebook as a gateway drug.
There's a phone call ad on
Facebook which I brought up
to you, I really
want you to do that.
It's an ad that is underused
because small businesses
are underusing Facebook,
and big companies,
Coke and Pepsi and BMW
don't want you to call them.
So it's an ad that has creative
but it also has a button
for the phone, and
as you guys all know,
now we look at Facebook on this,
not on your desktop as
much, so when you see it,
you press one
button and you're calling.
So, Facebook,
Facebook, Facebook.
Targeted, geo-located to the
Winnipeg area,
that would be the place.
And again, because
we have limited time,
there's a website, all of
you should write this down.
This is probably the information
gateway you're looking for.
There's a website,
I'll spell it for you,
and that's where you can get
deeper information about this.
It's spelled G,
O,
G,
(audience laughs)
L,
E.
And here's why
I'm making that joke.
If you wanna say, "How
do I make Facebook video
"for a small business,"
you type that into Google
and you'll have plenty of
articles and plenty of videos.
This is like exercise.
You know what to do, you
just don't want to do it.
So, now I can give
you one good answer,
now that I've understood
where you're coming from
and what you react to:
get great at Facebook.
We're gonna have two to three
years, everybody in this room
that doesn't listen to me, in
three years, will regret it
when all the articles of
2020 is, now it costs $80
to get in front of 1,000 people
on Facebook instead of $6.
We all "missed" it
from 2015 to 2020, got it?
- [Kathy] Got it.
- Because you know how
much the word wine cost
per click, in 2002?
Five cents.
Now it's $13.
Installing a
pool cost five cents.
Now it's
probably something else.
And so that's what's
gonna happen on Facebook,
that's why I'm pushing you all.
It's a supply and demand.
Everybody wants to get to a
40-year-old female in Winnipeg,
a 40-year-old female in
Calgary,
a 40-year-old woman in New York.
They're the decision maker
of so many transactions.
You're not competing
with everybody in this room,
you're competing with
every business in the world
'cause Facebook has to
keep the ads under control,
'cause if you get too
many ads, you're gonna leave,
so only so many
ads can get in there,
which means the price of the
ad will continue to go up
once people realize
how well it's working.
Supply and demand.
You're welcome.
- [Kathy] Thank you.
Let's get another
one over there.
Yeah.
- Hi, I'm Mary from Maryland,
from Regina Pools and Spas.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, how are you.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- Good, my question to
you is we've actually started
shooting Facebook Live videos,
because it sends a notification
out to our followers
that we're live, so
that they can come to us.
And shooting little
tidbit videos on how to maintain
a hot tub right now, because
pool season is closed for us.
- [Gary] Yup.
- Do you think that...
There's also Instagram Live,
but you can't do that at the
same time as Facebook Live.
- [Gary] You sure can.
- You can do it?
- [Gary] Yeah, you just
have to get a second phone.
- Yeah, well yes, there's that.
(audience laughter)
- [Gary] Guys, I'm a genius!
- But my question to you is--
- [Gary] So definitely do that!
- Yes, so we'll get
a second video going.
If we're not
doing Facebook Live,
and you're telling
people to shoot content,
what kind of camera?
Should we just use iPhones,
or should we actually go
get a camera and some mics?
- I think that the
iPhone is more than capable
to produce the quality video
that everybody in this room,
based on the size of
business that I believe is
in this room, needs, yeah.
- [Mary] Thank you.
- How is the
Facebook Live going for you?
- So we recently just
started it last month.
- [Gary] How many Facebook
fans do you have on your page?
- Not much.
- [Gary] How many?
- 465, I believe.
- [Gary] So I assume that means
you're getting one to two
people watching the streams.
- Yes, at the current
moment but some--
- [Gary] You know what,
I love you for that.
I don't know, one to
two is better than zero.
- Right, and we
get a couple likes.
The first couple videos,
we've only done three.
The first two
got around 200 views,
and then our third one
actually got over 300 views,
so it's slowly--
- When you finally post it,
make sure you're adding
a link to drive to a conversion.
- [Mary] Right, so that's
something that
we haven't been doing,
but as you were speaking today,
that is something in my
notes to do for the next one.
- Because what I like
is when people are trying
to be pioneers
and do new things...
Like, you know
what old man Stan, 67,
sitting over there and thought
about 300 views, jack crap.
He wants to know what
it meant for the business.
And so for me, what I like is
I don't care how many likes,
I don't care how many
followers, I don't care.
I mean, I care because it's
a proxy normally if you're
good at it to where it's going.
I wanna figure out
where does it lead to.
And the good part is
you're just starting.
Like to me, back to
patience, reason I said
the first six months
scare me with you,
like the biggest fear
I have here is this was a good
session, it was this,
and then you know,
you're gonna go out of
business if you don't listen,
then it's been
detailed, and da da.
It's all this, and there's
like nine to 15, to 22 people
that are sitting here
saying, you know what?
Yes, this is gonna...
Oh, and it's January 4,
exactly, so we're like yeah,
this is the year!
You know, it's all that stuff,
but it's hard and it takes time.
Right, now what I'm excited
about, back to pool season,
I don't know when people
decide that, or service it,
or buy that, or what have
you but if you can do this
hard and well, and
learn for the next three,
four, five, six months,
really nice early things
can start happening
the back end of this year.
And then '18 can be
really interesting.
I just wanna make
sure everybody understands
the advice I'm giving here,
if you decide to go look
deeper and you look at it,
it's not easy, it's called work.
This isn't a I'm gonna
miraculously hire
this 22-year-old.
22-year-olds use Snapchat
and Instagram to hook up.
(audience laughter)
Not sell pools.
It's a different skill set,
but they do understand it.
Cool, thanks.
- [Mary] Thank you.
- Any other questions?
Yeah, that's good, this
will be the last question.
Thank you guys so
much for your attention.
- [Ava] Hey, I'm Ava from
West Bernard, Louisiana,
and we live in a
very small area about,
all of our little small areas,
maybe 60,000 people.
- [Gary] Okay.
So, our Facebook following,
currently, is 231, to be exact.
How do you know if
you're actually reaching enough
for your area?
We only have one
other competitor,
they have about 400 followers.
How can we maximize
getting our customers
to our Facebook page?
- [Gary] So, I think
and is your ambition to
continue to service that 60,000?
- [Ava] Huh?
- Are you guys
gonna expand the business,
do you want more locations?
Do you want to go
into other cities?
Or this is a family business,
this is what you're doing?
- Family business,
this is what we're doing.
- Great, I would go knock
on all 60,000 homes, door.
- [Ava] Realistic.
- I'm being dead, seriously.
I swear on my children's
health that I would spend
the rest of my life
trying to build a relationship
with all 60,000
people individually,
because I think it can be done,
it's not that big of a number.
I'm being dead serious.
So the way I would do
that to scale is if I ran your
business, I would
probably try to invent a
town wide event
that everybody went to,
that I was the
owner of that event,
and used the event as
the gateway to be the biggest
business in town.
I would create the
annual 100 meter dash,
or pickle eating contest.
I'm being dead
serious with you by the way.
And then the content
would be about the event
because when you have
such a small circumference,
you can really do
the thank you economy
in hand-to-hand combat, and so
I'd probably run Facebook,
I wouldn't care
about likes at all.
231 versus 400 means nothing.
I would probably run some
Facebook ads
against the zip code,
and I would try to
literally meet them.
I'm not kidding, I would think
a lot about event marketing.
I mean, I assume
you're not spending
a lot of money on marketing.
- Actually, none.
- [Gary] Right,
that makes sense.
- We have good word of mouth.
- [Gary] Of course,
so you're basically sitting
and waiting for
people to call you?
- [Ava] Absolutely.
- I hate the
living shit out of that.
(audience laughter)
- But we do, we offer
so much for our community,
and we're so well known that...
My father-in-law
owns the business,
and his mentality is I
don't need to spend money
on marketing when we
have as much business
as we can handle
at this current time.
So we're kind of--
- [Gary] Listen, I can't
deploy my thesis or ambition
on your father-in-law.
Like, when I hear that
we have more business than
we can handle, my mind
goes to you better hire
a bunch more people, jerk.
(audeince laughter)
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Family dynamics.
(audience laughter)
Thank you guys, thank you!
(audience applause)